it is so nice to see you so nice of you
to stop by you look
absolutely incredible you know what i
put this outfit on
and i always uh confirm with my wife if
i look cool
you know and she was like hmm she gave
me a
hmm yeah she said i like it
but do you see i love when people say do
you
she said so do you yeah
she stopped herself do you yeah and i'm
doing me baby yeah come on now
that's funny cause that's funny
hey i got to tell you i call i call this
i call this the half heisman it's like
this
[Laughter]
add that to your repertoire man yeah
it's funny if you're long and lean
i'm no offense you're lonely you're long
and lean man when you're long and lean
like that
you do the half heisman tip like one
tippy toe
like this like this handling pocket
stand
stand the [ __ ] up first of all stand up
i know it's just weird and look away
from people like
like someone calling you over there
i'm like a frightened bird
you know i don't it doesn't work for me
i think it works for you
yeah you know are you excited so many
people are excited that this
this man it's 15 months of this pandemic
everyone's excited about different
things
restaurants are opening up are you
excited for restaurants
i am so excited for restaurants man
conan andy i just love them i think uh
it's we need to get them back on their
feet
you know and i just love going out and
seeing people
having a good time and talking and
mingling you know and see me
i go to restaurants see i'm a
connoisseur of fine food
see i i don't i don't read menus i i
haven't read a menu in 25 years
you don't look at all at the menu a menu
is for amateurs that's
amateur stuff anyway i can read a damn
menu i go to the restaurant
i have my wife the menu so dead baby get
what the hell you want
see and i sit back and when the waiter
comes over he says
what do you guys have i said give my
lady what she wants and i'm going to
have the special
yeah you always at you always ask for
the special always
and then i say i'm gonna have a special
then when he begins to tell me the
special
i say shut the [ __ ] up
this is this is your night it's not
about him this is your night
they say shut the [ __ ] up i didn't ask
you what the special was i said then
bring me the special yes see
now the pressure that takes yeah yeah
pressure is on the chef and that in
in that kitchen yeah to impress me yeah
yeah yeah
okay now i think you could tone it down
a little bit no
it's all i'm saying you could tone it
down same attitude but just take it down
a little bit oh man
no now that's what amateurs see
when everybody turns when you say shut
the [ __ ] up
i didn't tell you to tell me the special
i said to bring me the special
yeah listen yeah
you know i i thought you had gone too
far and then you said it again and i
realized you were pitch perfect
hey let me tell you something let me
tell you something
you are there to have a wonderful night
you know and people got to realize that
this guy
means business he wants that chef to be
on his best
yeah he wants the best meal tonight he's
been locked up on his pandemic
and he's just getting back out man i do
cool stuff too so i like to cross my leg
right so yeah sometimes
and what i do sometimes is i i'll cross
my leg over
the table like this well no you can't no
jb you can't do that that's you can't do
that no it's working
and then and then i put my leg over a
candle like this
and i hold it there until my sock starts
to smoke
okay a little bit and then i put it down
like that i don't see the point of that
at all that's just that's just pure
idiocy
people respect that conan they respect
that
yeah just like question lego over just
just like that just like this hold it
there
you know how many you know how many
single socks i have now
i know i have ruined so many right socks
man